>>> WE ARE BACK WITH OUR WORLD
LEAD.
A CNN EXCLUSIVE, YOU HEARD
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S PROMISE DURING
HIS CNN TOWN HALL, THE UNITED
STATES, HE SAID, WILL DEFEND
TAIWAN IF IT IS ATTACKED BY
CHINA.
THE WHITE HOUSE LATER WALKED
BACK THOSE REMARKS BUT NOW
TAIWAN'S PRESIDENT TELLS CNN SHE
IS CONFIDENT THE U.S. WOULD STEP
UP IF BEIJING TRIED TO MAKE A
MOVE ON THE DEMOCRATIC ISLAND.
THOSE COMMENTS COMING FROM THE
PRESIDENT'S FIRST INTERNATIONAL
TV INTERVIEW IN NEARLY TWO YEARS
WHERE SHE ALSO TELLS OUR WILL
RIPLEY THE THREAT FROM CHINA IS
INCREASING EVERY SINGLE DAY.
>> Reporter: AT THIS TEMPLE IN
TAIPEI, PRAYER AND POLITICS GO
HAND IN HAND FOR TAIWAN
PRESIDENT TSAI ING-WEN.
>> NORMALLY WHEN I GO TO THE
TEMPLE, THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF
PEOPLE THERE.
I WILL SHAKE HANDS WITH EACH ONE
OF THEM.
>> PEOPLE ARE REMARKABLY HAPPY,
AT EASE.
>> YOU HAVE TO GET A SENSE THAT
THERE'S SOMEBODY THERE TO TAKE
CARE OF THEM.
>> Reporter: ELECTED IN 2016,
TSAI WON RE-ELECTION BY A
LANDSLIDE LAST YEAR ON A PROMISE
TO KEEP PEOPLE SAFE FROM WHAT
SHE CALLS A GROWING THREAT
ACROSS THE TAIWAN STRAIT.
IS TAIWAN MORE SAFE TODAY THAN
IT WAS WHEN YOU BECAME PRESIDENT
IN 2016?
>> IF IT'S A THREAT FROM CHINA,
IT'S INCREASING EVERY DAY.
>> Reporter: THE MAINLAND'S
MASSIVE MILITARY, 2 MILLION
STRONG, MORE POWERFUL THAN EVER.
CHINA FLEW 150 WAR PLANES NEAR
TAIWAN IN JUST FIVE DAYS THIS
MONTH.
THIS DEMOCRACY OF MORE THAN 23
MILLION GOVERNED SEPARATELY FROM
THE MAINLAND FOR MORE THAN 70
YEARS SINCE THE END OF CHINA'S
CIVIL WAR, STILL SEEN AS A
BREAKAWAY PROMISE IN THE EYES OF
BEIJING'S COMMUNIST RULERS WHO
HAVE NEVER CONTROLLED THE
ISLAND.
CHINA HAS PRESSURED MOST OF THE
WORLD TO SEVER FORMAL DIPLOMATIC
TIES WITH TAIPEI.
CHINESE PRESIDENT XI JINPING
SAYS REUNIFICATION IS ONLY A
MATTER OF TIME.
ARE YOU INTERESTED IN SPEAKING
WITH PRESIDENT XI?
WOULD YOU LIKE TO HAVE MORE
COMMUNICATION WITH HIM?
>> WELL, MORE COMMUNICATION
WOULD BE HELPFUL SO THAT WE
WOULD REDUCE MISUNDERSTANDING
GIVEN OUR DIFFERENCES.
DIFFERENCES IN TERMS OF OUR
POLITICAL SYSTEMS.
WE CAN SIT DOWN AND TALK ABOUT
OUR DIFFERENCES AND TRY TO MAKE
ARRANGEMENT SO THAT WE WILL BE
ABLE TO CO-EXIST PEACEFULLY.
>> YOUR PREDECESSOR DID MEET
WITH PRESIDENT XI.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT THINGS --
THE COMMUNICATION HAS REALLY
GONE SOUTH SINCE 2016?
>> WELL, I THINK THE SITUATION
HAS CHANGED A LOT.
AND CHINA'S PLAN TOWARDS THE
REGION IS VERY DIFFERENT.
>> THAT PLAN INCLUDES MORE
THREATS OVER TAIWAN.
CLASHES WITH JAPAN AND THE EAST
CHINA SEA.
AND MILITARIZING MANMADE ISLANDS
IN THE SOUTH CHINA SEA.
POSING A DIRECT CHALLENGE TO
SEVEN DECADES OF U.S. MILITARY
SUPREMACY IN THE INDO-PACIFIC.
IN RESPONSE, THE U.S. RAMPED UP
ARMS SALES TO TAIWAN.
SELLING THE ISLAND $5 BILLION IN
WEAPONS LAST YEAR.
PRESIDENT TSAI CONFIRMS TO CNN,
U.S. SUPPORT GOES BEYOND SELLING
WEAPONS.
>> DOES THAT SUPPORT INCLUDE
SENDING SOME U.S. SERVICE
MEMBERS TO HELP TRAIN TAIWANESE
TROOPS?
>> WELL, YES.
WE HAVE A WIDE RANGE OF
COOPERATION WITH THE U.S.
AIMED AT INCREASING OUR DEFENSE
CAPABILITY.
>> HOW MANY U.S. SERVICE MEMBERS
ARE DEPLOYED IN TAIWAN RIGHT
NOW?
>> NOT AS MANY AS PEOPLE
THOUGHT.
>> Reporter: DEFENSE DEPARTMENT
RECORDS SHOW THE NUMBER OF U.S.
TROOPS IN TAIWAN INCREASED FROM
10 IN 2018 TO 32 EARLIER THIS
YEAR.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT ASKED FOR
MORE MARINES TO SAFEGUARD THE
UNOFFICIAL U.S. EMBASSY IN
TAIPEI.
ANY U.S. MILITARY PRESENCE IN
TAIWAN, BIG OR SMALL, IS
PERCEIVED BY BEIJING AS AN ACT
OF AGGRESSION.
WHEN REPORTS SURPASSED EARLIER
THIS MONTH OF U.S. MARINES
TRAINING TAIWANESE TROOPS, CHINA
RELEASED THIS VIDEO.
A TRAINING EXERCISE TARGETING
TAIWAN INDEPENDENCE AND
INTERFERENCE BY EXTERNAL FORCES
LIKE THE U.S.
A WARNING FOR PRESIDENT JOE
BIDEN WHO VOWED TO DEFEND TAIWAN
AT THIS CNN TOWN HALL LAST WEEK.
>> SO ARE YOU SAYING THAT THE
UNITED STATES WOULD COME TO
TAIWAN'S DEFENSE IF CHINA
ATTACKED?
>> YES, WE HAVE A COMMITMENT TO
DO THAT.
>> Reporter: THE WHITE HOUSE
LATER WALKED BACK BIDEN'S
COMMENTS.
THEY SEEMED TO CONTRADICT THE
U.S. POLICY OF STRATEGIC
AMBIGUITY.
LEAVING U.S. MILITARY
INVOLVEMENT IN TAIWAN AN OPEN
QUESTION.
>> PEOPLE HAVE DIFFERENT
INTERPRETATION OF WHAT PRESIDENT
BIDEN HAS SAID.
>> DO YOU HAVE FAITH THAT THE
UNITED STATES WOULD DEFEND
TAIWAN IF THE MAINLAND WERE TO
TRY TO MOVE ON TAIWAN?
>> I DO HAVE FAITH.
AND GIVEN THE LONG-TERM
RELATIONSHIP THAT WE HAVE WITH
THE U.S. AND ALSO THE SUPPORT OF
THE PEOPLE OF THE U.S. AS WELL
AS THE CONGRESS AND THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN VERY
HELPFUL.
>> Reporter: TAIWAN'S DEFENSE
MINISTER SAYS CHINA COULD LAUNCH
A FULL-SCALE WAR BY 2025.
HE SAYS MILITARY TENSIONS ARE
THE WORST IN MORE THAN 40 YEARS.
>> WE HAVE TO EXTRADITE OUR
MILITARY REFORM SO THAT WE HAVE
THE ABILITY TO DEFEND OURSELVES.
AND GIVEN THE SIZE OF TAIWAN
COMPARED TO THE SIZE OF THE PRC,
DEVELOPING A SYMMETRIC
CAPABILITY IS THE KEY FOR US.
>> HOW PREPARED IS TAIWAN TODAY?
>> WE ARE TRYING TO MAKE US
STRONGER IN EVERY ASPECT.
THAT INCLUDES OUR MILITARY
CAPABILITY.
AND OUR INTERNATIONAL SUPPORT.
>> Reporter: SUPPORT BOLSTERED,
SHE SAYS, BY TAIWAN'S CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE TO THE GLOBAL SUPPLY
CHAIN.
THE ISLAND IS A WORLD LEADER IN
SEMICONDUCTORS.
TAIWAN WAS ASIA'S FASTEST
GROWING ECONOMY LAST YEAR.
A FACT PRESIDENT TSAI PROUDLY
POINTS OUT OVER LUNCH.
>> THIS IS ONE OF MY FAVORITE
FOODS.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> Reporter: DESPITE EVERYTHING,
SHE APPEARS CALM AND CONFIDENT.
>> YOU TALKED ABOUT HOW REALLY
THE SITUATION IS SO COMPLEX NOW.
>> IT IS VERY COMPLEX.
THIS IS PROBABLY THE MOST
CHALLENGING TIME FOR PEOPLE OF
TAIWAN.
>> Reporter: YOU READ THE
OUTSIDE HEADLINES.
THE MOST DANGEROUS PLACE ON
EARTH.
>> WE READ THESE REPORTS AS
REMINDER TO US AS TO WHAT
THREATS WE'RE UNDER AND WE HAVE
TO GET OURSELVES BETTER
PREPARED.
BUT WE'RE NOT PANICKED.
WE'RE NOT ANXIOUS BECAUSE WE
HAVE GONE THROUGH SO MANY
DIFFICULTIES IN THE PAST.
>> Reporter: SHE SAYS TAIWAN'S
FUTURE MUST BE DECIDED BY ITS
PEOPLE.
THE PEOPLE WHO WORKED HARD OVER
THE LAST 70 YEARS TO BUILD THE
WORLD'S ONLY CHINESE SPEAKING
DEMOCRACY.
A DEMOGERACY UNDER GROWING
THREAT.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME IN MORE
THAN 40 YEARS THAT A TAIWANESE
PRESIDENT HAS PUBLICLY CONFIRMED
U.S. TROOPS ARE HERE ON THE
ISLAND TRAINING TAIWANESE
TROOPS.
IT COMES AT A TIME THE U.S. IS
CALLING FOR A MORE MEANINGFUL
ROLE FOR TAIWAN AT THE UNITED
NATIONS.
MUCH TO THE IRE OF BEIJING WHICH
JUST YESTERDAY SAID IT'S NOT
RULING OUT THE USE